[Musique]
premier match de l'équipe de france dans
cet euro 2020 plusieurs établissements
évinois diffuser le match les bleus ont
remporté la victoire avec un but inscrit
par un joueur allemand contre son camp
des assouplissements inattendu le
premier ministre a annoncé la fin de
l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur sauf dans certains cas mais
aussi la levée du couvre-feu à 23 heures
qui sera effective dimanche 20 juin avec
10 jours d'avancé
quatre petites chouettes de l'espace
rambouillet viennent de s'envoler vers
l'allemagne
les le 15 mai dernier d'un couple de
chouettes appartenant à la société les
ailes de l'urgent arts et au parc
animalier un transfert dans le cadre du
programme de réhabilitation de l'âge
fait de l'oural en bavière
trois centres de vaccination vont fermer
leurs portes dans les yvelines à la
suite d'une baisse de la demande
château à partir du 13 juillet
rambouillet le 17 et bonnières sur seine
le 30 juillet quarante élèves du lycée
saint françois d'assise de montigny le
bretonneux en ont appris un peu plus sur
l'astronomie
ils ont suivi un échange en direct avec
l'astronaute français thomas pesquet
depuis l'observatoire de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
les journées européennes de
l'archéologie ont bien lieu cette année
à cette occasion le musée national
d'archéologie de saint-germain-en-laye
propose des activités dédiées et
l'ouverture de pièces normalement fermée
au public
[Musique]